tick tock let's go for breakfast
nothing i don't eat breakfast the
propaganda around breakfast being the
most important meal is propaganda from
the
cereal and dairy industry it's not true
it's not true it's propaganda breakfast
is a lie
actually food is a lie it was invented
by companies
global conglomerates are in your brains
get it out you're not hungry you don't
need
substance dance i mean to be fair
cereals is probably not the best
breakfast but you can still have
breakfast all right there are plenty of
healthy
delicious breakfast meals that you can
put into your daily routine and help you
start your day with good energy and
ready to fight the
man i thought that was you man chad from
boy scouts bro what's up bro how you
doing bro
what's up chad hey what's going on with
you man
chris oh you chris yeah that's what it
was christian boy scouts man what's up
man how you doing man
oh my god yes this is so uncomfortable
oh my gosh
it's been a long time it's one long time
man
man it's all right man don't worry how
are you doing there you are my boyfriend
brett all right
hey once a boy scout always a boy scout
chad just want to pick up some
spinach hey what's going on i thought
that was you man
chris oh no you're chad look at that's a
chat right there all right a lot of
people out there playing the lottery and
i've got a lot better idea than playing
the lottery
what about putting out life insurance on
a random logger check okay
one million dollars in life insurance
only seventy five dollars
the odds of a lot of dying on the job
are about one in every three thousand
are you serious is that high it's that
high
33.3 out of every hundred thousand which
means three out of every ten
thousand which means one out of every
three thousand
the odds of winning lotto max are about
one in thirty three million
do the math life insurance winnings
aren't even taxed
oh jesus look at the roads i drive down
plus you can use that asymmetric
information to your advantage the
insurance company doesn't know that i
like rock climbing and exploring
abandoned mines on my days off
problem is you can't take out life
insurance i'm just a random person so i
can take it out in my name name somebody
else's beneficiary
charge them a hundred dollars a month
and then pay the 75 putting 25 dollars
into my pocket
it's this guy's convincing am i getting
roped into insurance fraud here what is
happening
why does this make so much sense which
means if we can convince a thousand
people to do this
i'll make twenty five thousand dollars a
month and the lottery may have to pay
out a billion dollars if i die which
means they'll want to protect their
investment
which means i can probably convince them
to buy me a t-54 russian battle tank for
a daily driver
that has one of the finest crash test
safety ratings oh that's such
a good tick tock what the hell did i
just watch
bro just give the man his tank come on
lottery
just give the man his tank if you kick
every latino out of this country all
right the the classic
the classic logic of what is her name
kelly osbourne
i've already seen this a million times
but latino out of this country
then who is going to be cleaning your
toilet donald trump oh
that's in the sense that you know what i
mean like
she was so hoping everyone was going to
be like
yeah got him wait
what the [ __ ] did you just say what what
are you saying with a
that's not what i meant in l.a they
always
but they're in l.a keep going like that
come on
pick an accent already you ain't [ __ ]
british in here
shut the [ __ ] up it's still a monster
wait what sweet wait wait what
wait what have you done a deer over
there
what did i just watch like a weird fever
dream i never
want to see that again round of applause
and watch their reactions
[Music]
i gotta try this with that gear edgar
bro you can't sleep
all the time here hey okay
okay okay hey okay
yeah you go
yeah let's go you're the best dog
you win best dog award you win all the
new awards
you get free food forever you actually
do it
all right you're sleepy oh my god you're
so tired
look at this dude look at this dude look
he's just gonna sink into it all right
there he goes
i got hairy legs that turned that
that that that that that turn uh um
okay so somehow because i like like two
videos of joe biden saying random stuff
this is all i get in my feed now and i
am so confused
and the kids used to come up and reach
in the pool and rub my leg down
so it was straight and then watch the
hair come back
up again they'd look at it so i learned
about roaches i learned about kids
jumping on my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
but
stop stop it stop
stop it let's stop you right there stop
can i stop president kenyon
what's the context that's quite i'm sure
there's a logical explanation
all right i know what this is
he's got a point yeah all right let's
lip sync read what is he saying
we're obviously changing the background
music it's a dojo cat
for some reason uh weasel471 posted this
what is he trying to tell us there must
be a hidden meaning
[Music]
a bloody stupid in it that's what it
says i can read the lips
okay yeah i knew about this but it makes
sense
i'm positive that people who claim
they've seen aliens have actually just
seen baby owls
kill them kill the owls bruh
okay i'm about to show you something
that may give you nightmares
forever indefinitely but i think it's
necessary
that we can so river dolphins might say
introduced these to me
and ever since i saw one i never want to
see one again but i think
you know everyone always says oh so sad
when species get the extent
but i think i would be okay with this
one going river dolphins
they can go they had a good run how many
millions of years have they lived
too many millions they look like a sea
penis
am i the only one seeing this i don't
want to swim with sweet penis i don't
i don't care 40 million years ago all
right your time is done
you're done dolphins river dolphins
you're done
or was i talking about baby owls
yeah they can go too they're done you're
done baby else how long i'll live
long enough okay
wait you actually look some kid
[Laughter]
she fell in water idiot i like the face
of her friend when she realizes
hold up look at it look at him casual
what kind of what kind of water is this
this is river dolphin water she better
go
up fast it's coming for her what's the
one thing you can never live with
never live without my family what's the
one thing you can
never live without can't live without my
kkw contour
same i mean her marketing is on point
you gotta hand it to her
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
englishman no more bye well done sweden
everyone ganks uh up till la join space
360. let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go ally hey with the clutch
it's too fast i can't keep up man
console gamers be like bro
get out of here
[Music]
[Laughter]
good laugh okay
another species we need to cancel a
single cell organism look at this
it just sucks it up and becomes safe
what is that why does he do that
don't all right i'm done with nature am
i i'm tired of pretending oh nature's so
good to need
no you go you go away now okay
how have signs not exterminated this huh
i'm joking by the way in case it wasn't
playing the obvious but still
but still am i so this is from a
streamer named kit
boga i've seen him before but this clip
in particular
is just absolutely golden you're getting
it for your own
i won't get it so what he does is he
tricks scammers
i won't get it i won't get it
what do you mean ma'am what are you
doing
what are you doing are you a prostitute
ma'am you're a prostitute man
you are redeeming it he really wanted
that google credit
it really what movie was it i won't get
it
what do you mean desperation
what are you doing
did you see it did you catch it
come on throw the ball grandpa
what are you doing oh sorry that wake
you up here
oh throw the bar throw it
oh you're a stinky boy he's sweating
people say dogs don't sweat i can tell
like they're sweating right now
which eye do you guys look out of i look
out of that one
the [ __ ] did you just do to me which i
do guys
this didn't work it doesn't work the
first time i saw it i was like what the
[ __ ]
i mean you do have a dominant eye don't
you it is a thing you can test it
how do you test it again is it
all right we can do this together to
find your dominant eye
create a triangle using your thumbs and
forefingers as shown here
now frame a distant object such as a
clock on a wall within this triangle
keeping both your eyes open then close
your left eye
if the object stays centered your right
eye
is your dominant eye if the object moves
out of center
your left eye is your dominant eye well
what if it doesn't stay
at any center where they didn't it moved
on both of them
hello hello i need more info it's about
perhaps but it would be uncommon what
the [ __ ] is wrong what
[Music]
they both move what am i supposed to do
it's more like a person has mixed ocular
dominance
[Music]
get that right ah stupid science
all right we're canceling science next
bruh look at this dude
this fat son of a [ __ ] has seen his
last days and he knows it
[Music]
run run run man come on you can still do
it he can't run
[Music]
wait is that a rat or is it a hamster
what is it
it's a hamster oh okay okay
this is the reason for why i'm charging
for people to use my okay i can't tell
if this is real but you guys let me know
what you think i'm not sure
art as their profile picture i spend a
lot of time and energy
creating my art for you to just come in
and take my art and use it as your
profile picture
is disrespectful to the amount of time
energy and talent that goes into each
wood burning piece that i make
the fifty dollars it's my time and
energy
and therefore makes it okay for you to
utilize my art for your profile picture
if you refuse to do so i will contact my
lawyer
now it's in that real refusal to pay my
lawyer will then get your profile
picture taken down
thank you for being understanding and
thank you for supporting my small
business
bro i can't i mean like obviously
everyone is trolling her and doing the
avatar
but at the same time it's genius
marketing because if they're trick
everyone
they're so bad
they're so cute
so cute
[Applause]
[Music]
himself he'd just be scared you'll have
a great time in bryce and daphne just
don't bother going on the british
airways i316 it's yeah
and half an hour of your life that you
won't get back if you do that in mind
i'm not sure how many people they're
allowing on at the moment but if one of
them has coveted you all have covered
also it is a heavily air-conditioned
greenhouse so the moment you get on it
on a hot day you will need a wii which
is a hilarious sensation until you
remember there is no toilet on it
because of light coming through the
ceiling and the curvature of the windows
all you can actually see is the
reflection of yourself and your fellow
passengers
the best thing to look at are all the
little people below you don't want to
risk having to look at kent or hampshire
off in the distance or if you're really
unlucky you might see france the good
thing about being on the i360 is you get
half an hour where you don't need to
look at the i360 it's managed to take
the ugliest building on the seafront off
the old burnt help here which is no
oh man okay yeah this is insane to me
so the brighton pier they i'm full
conspiracy on the brighton pier
so i remember coming here and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that
and people are just like oh that's the
old pier i'm like
okay but but why is it
like that what the heck so it burned
down
not once but twice how does a pier
catch fire okay it's literally on water
twice as fire investigators
were unable to access the site for
safety reason the cause of fire was
unknown
okay they burned it down who did this
and then another one broke out that's
crazy
because it used to be uh beautiful like
look at this
incredible so yeah so instead of just
repairing the pier or restoring it which
you're obviously not going to do they
built the iso 360. so you can like look
out
on the ocean i don't know it annoys me i
don't understand
how these things happen i hate this
thing so much
they actually did good in the bottom it
looks okay the thing is
british airways bought it they somehow
put money into it
so you know how staples for different
countries usually lit up
their towers or their buildings with
with colored lights during certain
events and you know
maybe saint patty's day they lit it up
green or whatever
you know a theme different themed and
brighton being the
known as the gay capital of uk what
maybe during lgbt
pride month or whatever they can lit up
rainbow you know make things interesting
nope they just lit it up blue and
red because that's the colors of british
airways and that's all they do with it
it's just this great
power that looks like [ __ ] it costs 46
million to build
and 36 million was funded by public
works loan
oh i'm glad glad everyone got us saying
this
okay this is so cool you remember this
old clip
that is so cool
dice put it in the trailer for their new
reveal
wait we gotta watch it so the guy that
recorded the the clip and made a
reaction to it
he's russian
it's gonna blow its mind
[Laughter]
thank you so much
it's wholesome as hell dude love that
loved
that alright mates i believe that's
enough tick tock for today if you
enjoyed this video
smash that subscribe check out other
video epic say bye to it
don't be rude okay that's enough